car diouf bonjour bonjour c'est une
bonne question à quoi ça sert c'est ça
le prix la devise russe dans la vie mais
à leur décharge c'est pas toujours des
saloperies quand même les virus je pense
que il faut rappeler aux gens que les
virus
on entend beaucoup parler quand on a une
maladie qui nous frappe ou une pandémie
comme celle que traverse la planète
aujourd'hui mais c'est peut-être mais
les entités biologiques les plus
représentés dans la biosphère à terme
donneront les retrouve partout partout
partout il ya un violeur de l'université
de colombie britannique qui s'appelle
quartier satin qui acquit qui présente
souvent sans enfants de 2 et de façon
très imagée il disait si remettez on a
grandi c'est chaque virus qui se trouve
dans un corps humain à la grosseur d'un
point d'une épingle bain en êtres
vivants comme moi comme vous pas prise
il mesurait quelque chose comme 150 km
ça montre un peu à quel point mes étés
biologiques sont omniprésentes dans la
biosphère ce soir des hans et c'est tant
scientifique parce que leurs origines
remontent aux premiers balbutiements de
la vie sur la planète dont alors il y en
a beaucoup beaucoup car ça on a compris
ça il ya un beau couple
et c'est pas nécessairement négative
mais alors je vous pose la question oui
ça sert à quoi
très bien ça existe parce que je pense
que la nature non non ne crée pas les
choses dans un design particulier on
pourrait poser la même question à quoi
ça sert un être humain je pense que
personne ne pourrait répondre c'est une
bonne avec les bulls les bulls sont là
on les retrouve beaucoup envient des
océaniques beaucoup beaucoup énormément
à milieu océanique
on les retrouve jusque dans les traces
de nos jeunes parce que 5 à 10% dans le
dos non j'aime ce sont des jeunes qui
viennent des vices de notre adn vient
des virus alors à milieu marin on sait à
quoi servent les virus ambiants en au
moins on s'est un peu parce qu'on ne
sait pas tout sur les virus mais en
milieu marin les virus sont très
nombreux on dit souvent que
dans une cuillère doute même il ya
autant de virus de la population si le
continent européen au complet et que
chaque fois qu'on savait on agit on
absorbe la approximativement 1 milliard
de milliards d'autres sont très nombreux
et en milieu marin ben rhodes un des
rôles qui a publié au virus crdd espèce
de légende équilibre dans la boucle
microbienne dans le gruyère monde
microscopique du marais les virus en
europe ils maintiennent l'équilibré a
été aussi que j'aime bien si tu es si on
doit s'en cherche une région qui dit ça
s'appelle la thur la théorie des kills
the winner ça veut dire tu es le plus
fort donc dans le cuir monde des
microbes en milieu marin car les
ressources sont limitées
les virus s'attaque préférentiellement à
l'espèce qui est dominante et qu'ils
s'approprient toutes les ressources
comme un frein les freins
voilà quand tu es très compétitif et tu
parles toutes les ressources les virus
vos d'humilier cette espèce pour donner
de la place aux plus faibles et donc
augmenter la biodiversité dans le milieu
marin dont qui tue beaucoup de micro
organismes dans le milieu marin qui si
l'on roule dans le cycle du carbone
chez nous on les utilise dans à beaucoup
d'autres choses on les utilise un génie
génétique
on les utilise en cancérologie pour
traiter des tumeurs on les utilise aussi
et nous rendre service en tient des
bactéries qui nous rend malades aussi
donc ça et ils ne sont pas en soi vivent
ça n'est qu'ils doivent être collées sur
une cellule sur quelque chose de vivant
pour pouvoir vivre le virus je ne vis
pas exactement c'est pour ça que les
scientifiques ont de la difficulté à les
classer dans le ventre du vivant où le
rôle des inertes
alors donc ce qui est plus admis
maintenant c'est que quand le vieux
c'est dans une cellule
on le considère comme un objet vivant et
qu'à l'extérieur de la cellule on
considère comme quelque chose d'inepte
parce que la différence entre un virus
et une bactérie de ce côté là c'est que
la bactérie là tout l'outillage
qui est nécessaire pour se reproduire ça
et le juriste n'a pas ça donc le virus
pirates le système d'une cellule doc se
fixe une cellule en dedans et dire à
l'intérieur de la cellule
voilà six mois le maire mais maintenant
vous allez faire ce que je veux pour
assurer la reproduction donc et le virus
transport transforme les cellules qu'ils
parasitent en mère porteuse fort c est
ce qui fait que les cellules le travail
que la cellule devait faire en temps
normal si on prend l'exemple de dudus
accorde 2 qui est le but de keane qui
nous concerne maintenant ben sa cible
préférentielle d'après les scientifiques
c'est beaucoup les cellules épithéliales
qui tapissent l'intérieur des pouvoirs
et ses cellulaires au rôle dans le
nettoyage des poumons à ce sont des
sémites signé et ceux qui arrivent ceux
qui carburent israël dans ses cellules
par le contrôle de leurs machineries et
le redis je vous mets au service de ma
propre réplication multiplication les
celi ne peut plus assurer le monde qu'il
faisait avant donc les gens se ramasse
avec des problèmes respiratoires parce
que le fond tu le pouvoir ne fonctionne
plus de façon optimale un peu c'est ça
c'est vraiment des des parasites qui ont
le désir de contrôler une cellule est de
mettre toute sa machinerie à lens et
nice mais d'un point de vue
philosophique ce que vous avez dit sur
les virus marin qui s'attaque aux
espèces trop dominante pour préserver un
équilibre il demande parallèle peut être
fait preuve d'un froid pendant des
années sur les débordements humains sur
la planète et que ce virus là est venu
en tout cas mettre une en pose beaucoup
beaucoup de choses pour une réflexion
mais je car dieu je vous salue merci
beaucoup aux artistes